I gotta meet this kid miss Dobson yes
this is she
how you doing this Carmelo Anthony I
want to talk to you about your son
he's down at MTSU he's my papa
that's what I hear I want to know if I
could come down there meet him one day
let me call his coach I appreciate that
talk some dedication God's patience some
more my sacrifice I'm doing away don'twe
talk about a one's leg now you hear what
I've been saying
at acacia
[Music]
that's tilted I just don't understand
like why everything happened it was like
we would literally chillin like when
doing nothing
three years ago in Knoxville Tennessee
sag Thompson and his brother Xavier
which is laughing on a porch say died
Sacre
he's tackling an all too familiar
situation moving on from tragedy back
home making moves to be a better player
in a better man all with a smile on his
face
this is Texas Avenue we're coming up on
the house that exact Savion and more
kasemir were raised up in hey that's
when he won 16 21 16 this year that's
where the boys will raise up it on the
side of the half it was there was their
field that's actually where the girls
started hmm is everyone a put he will
push that to his limits he was like my
little big brother basically if I'm
there is they be under he's not far is
that cos AV I always I mean riding our
bikes going to the playground going to
the basketball court well I'm from the
hood master going on neighborhood like
shoes and everything but I mean we made
a way to really like stay away from our
like we was just doing our own pain in
our own world there was last day of
school it was bright then we went to the
floor and game
so we go home check them with my mama
shake the everything was cool so we end
up walking on the back street all we
have this long street we got up there we
just we just chilling then all of a
sudden we just see people walking
towards us in the street it did not get
up cuz I I know everybody in the
community like everybody know me my mom
and my brothers I'm like okay this ain't
the same I've happen as soon as I took a
step off the porch soon as I to my foot
understood they start shooting this one
I get the panicking just panicking yeah
I just took off I just took off running
I just took out run I just took off
a developing story in Knoxville
Tennessee is mourning a high school
football player sophomore standout who
had star potential who was killed by a
group of gunmen randomly targeted in a
shooting shot dead
Savion story has dominated social media
a teenager who's being hailed a hero
died trying to shield three girls three
young girls in a spasm of violence he
wasn't in the wrong place at the wrong
time he hadn't made a bad decision he
was exactly where any other kid would be
your kid my kids He gave His life to
save theirs an act of heroism
a lot bigger than anything we should
ever expect from a 15 year old it was it
was everywhere it was everywhere and
like I would say like I didn't really I
didn't really get to grieve however he
wanted to because like it was just so
much like it was the the media and just
how everything how are we thank God like
it was just I really didn't get the time
to really grieve the moment Zach stepped
on our campus he was full of energy very
talented not very large in stature but
played so much bigger than he really was
Savion followed him the year after just
because he didn't want to be Zach's
little brother he pushed to make a name
for itself and I think that pushed that
to continue
Zach was your school guy Savion was more
your bruiser linebacker type guy you
could see between his freshman and
sophomore year he figured out that this
is not useful everything I acted good
just good all of us
I was really like working out like crazy
I was doing footwork Jews almost every
night my gosh I 4:00 in the morning
Peenemunde don't matter
doing Footwear just like you know let's
go get this way they called their room
the lucky one
it smelled like a locker room as well
[Laughter]
like we had the most company it was like
I open home like she never had a problem
of our friends coming over it's about
love I mean it was my main thing a team
mom of all teen moms I mean she knew
every player they all knew her they felt
very comfortable around her if they
didn't have their grades they could play
ball if they didn't have their homework
they couldn't play ball they taught them
heart worthy or runners in defense as I
used to hit the fence and along with
hard work we won so that tall along the
hard work comes success and I think you
carry that with you to life the jury
they heard me
I'm his brother I was first hand like so
yeah are you a [ __ ] no are you in any
kind of game
[Music]
I said uh I said I'm not a gamer I'm an
athlete say down to hero and Zack had to
learn how to go to school without his
best friend how to play without his
favorite teammate how to live without
his brother and while Zack stood up to
accept awards and Jays honor
he was rebuilding the life of his own he
just felt responsible they thought this
avi was with him when he ran
I remember Zack not being able to come
to school for a while I mean it was
affecting him in a in a way that you
would imagine it would I never forget
this my coaches came to my house but I
felt like it was part of my job to go
get him back here and try to support him
and what a strong young man and I know
where that comes from I know that comes
from his mother every day was a struggle
he didn't want to go to school he didn't
want to get out of bed he had a mental
breakdown
I got like we did everything together so
he was always with me beside me at
breakfast with me so I just I just not
feeling
just depression I just didn't feel the
same I didn't feel myself just felt dark
it's real dark those times were used to
test me in life but I don't know what
they do wrong no no it's names for me I
used to tell me I used his third
sterling on my bow used to beat her he
didn't know how to handle his brother
not being anymore somebody grow with all
his life we were at a breaking point but
that support in the love that we have
for each other we just grabbed each
other a little tighter and held him he
didn't give up even though he wanted to
he was at the point of his life where he
could have he could have got revenge he
could have been better but he wanted to
represent a different way
it was either tonight or the next night
didn't happen I I take my coach I was
like I wanna changed my number 24
I want to wear saving on his number I
want to be number 24 next year he said
mama I I mean I know this was a VI Moni
I'm gonna live his next I'm gonna do
what it takes for my brother he wanted
to be a coach he wanted to be a coach
there's one thing I would never forget
that you money because you always tell
me he wanted to take my school I was
gonna straight-up let him pick
he was the football guru so I'm just I'm
gonna let him do it that's you this one
head is what they say if it's to offer
you they're gonna offer me to come your
brother now zach is out here at Middle
Tennessee State University there first
and his family on the college
scholarship playing wire receiver when
his brothers number making a name for
himself I think the thing that that
stands out the most about Zac is just
his overall athleticism people still
recruits mahogany play ball you can play
ball the ability to play multiple
positions because they played running
back he played wide receiver he played
defensive back
he returned kicks we never thought we
was coming true until his senior year
when we realized that Vince ncgobo
recruited us both and they both like
this was really buff his players like
they offer me I know there's more from
him eventually as soon as he got the
news that he was going to school is his
expressions and everything just changed
and then you could just see the life
just be pumped back into him once I got
here everything just kind of got back to
normal you know he rides that dang
skateboard
he's a while with he rent brushes right
now he a good guy good light-hearted
he fit in really fast you know in the
locker room because of his outgoing
personality you think you find the other
belt
just to make the atmosphere not dead he
does but he's got a great attitude he
comes to practice every day to work and
get
better and if he'll keep doing that and
he's got a chance to contribute more and
more as the season progresses shoulder
out there that's slowing down you got a
turn and run see that on there
you're faster than all these before
every game no I just going to hold under
mode I just think about just everything
that's happy to me I just be like his
timing it's time to go I haven't scored
yet but when I when I do is cool how is
pointing to sky though my 24 is up I'm
still a gas is a blessing really
that means she's reborn again like I got
a new life is born
my brother name is Avion William Dobson
so I I named him design window
Zack is still showing up has a
backflipping skateboarding life of the
party but let's be real Zack is more
than just a brother of a hero he is more
than a boy who Wayne
so I went to Middle Tennessee State to
find him because I wanted to remind them
all this is what hoodie season
[Music]
[Music]
good day mellow
[Applause]
what does hoodie melon means to you it's
a mentality so hoodie season for me it's
all about how you're able to just buckle
down lock in on what you got a lock in
noise AK I came out here for Zach and
the reason I came out here for Zach is
because of his story right and knowing
what he's been through and knowing kind
of what his family been through you're
still grounded you're still pushing
still rocking still here playing
football you could easily gave up right
you could easily fell victim to that
mentality uh y'all my brother is going
like with your mind that is right now
like that's what that's what I'm more
interested in here you know I mean I
don't try to put a passage that I didn't
try to put it back
really distract me give me Douglas keep
going keep going you're home then I got
a sign inside it is like I got another
reason do it yeah almost like a blessing
from a tragedy but you keep doing what
you're doing on the football field
because like I said in there all that
hard work pay off like everybody seen
our face oh yeah yeah
there's a love that's crazy that
conversation was more than just being an
athlete
what's rarely gets it not about
basketball this more than football it's
about you losing your brother like how
do you respond to that life is bigger
than sports but sports bring us together
but when we give what we can to each
other when we commit to each other when
we struggle together we win together
that's what real is having just living
life you live your life trying to make
it
[ __ ]
[Applause]
when I do is go how to smile is they
view as they be on every time
everybody knows so you praise the
carving alone and I'm like man I did not
know about this said oh you lying I'm
serious I know about it it's how a hook
will coming in who comes Nick that who
coming here this who named LeBron Katie
he took time out of his day came to see
me and talk to me Nessa that's love is
matter
this is Carmelo Anthony thanks for
watching to meet more heroes go to be
real bleacherreport.com